pour parler de cet accord historique
nous sommes en direct avec jean arthuis
ancien ministre et ancien député
européen bonjour monsieur arthuis merci
d'un direct avec nous sur rt france
alors après cet accord européen sur ce
plan de relance économique emmanuel
macron a parlé de moment historique
est ce que vous partagez l'entousiasme
du président pleinement l'helmand je
crois que c'est un événement depuis la
création de l'euro le jour on a créé
sept modèles uniques qu'on a on a pris
un biais d' aller sans retour vers une
forme d'intégration politique qui
malheureusement jusqu'à maintenant on
n'a pas suivi il manquait pour assurer
le bon fonctionnement la bonne
gouvernance de la zone euro
un recours à l'emprunt eh bien cette
fois c'est une étape supplémentaire
un nouveau garges pour aller vers une
gouvernance politique de l'union
européenne c'est un acte de solidarité
c'est le fruit et d'une décision
politique car c'est la chancelière
angela merkel et le président de la
république emmanuel macron qui le 18 mai
ont appelé à la définition et la mise en
oeuvre d'un plan de relance l'europe en
a beaucoup souffert et l'europe étaient
à la limite de sa survie est de son
implosion
puis-je rappeler que nous avons connu
trois crises majeures la crise
financière de 2008 avec les problèmes de
la grèce de quelques pays méditerranéens
l'émigration massive de 2014 et 2015 on
se demandait ce que faisait l'europe
et puis le break site qui a été une
rupture avec la grande bretagne
il fallait donc un acte politique majeur
et c'est ce qui s'est manifesté dans la
nuit de dimanche à lundi donc c'est en
effet une décision historique alors il
ya encore beaucoup de travail pour
définir les réglementations qui vont
permettre de la mise en oeuvre de ce
plan il ya eu simultanément l'adoption
de ce plan sans recours à l'emprunt qui
est sans précédent dans cette dans cette
importance de 750 milliards mais
également l'approbation de ski
le rendez vous tous les sept ans des
ambitions et des attentes des différents
pays de l'union européenne c'est à dire
le cadre financier pluriannuel qui fixe
le budget pour les sept années qui
viennent 2021 et 2027
nous sommes sous présidence allemande
depuis le 1er juillet et c'est c'est un
acquis considérable
c'est je crois en effet comme la dir est
modèle macro une décision historique
pour l'europe mais il y a encore
beaucoup de travail à accomplir
sept cent cinquante 50 milliards d'euros
est suffisant pour relancer justement
l'économie européenne à votre avis c'est
quand même très important il faudra que
chaque état puisse également prendre des
dispositions car l'europe apporte sa
contribution aux qu'on a recours à un
élément de solidarité cet emprunt
collectif qui sera remboursé
collectivement par les 27 pays de
l'union européenne mais ça suppose aussi
que chaque état membre prennent des
dispositions ce qui sera le cas en
france puisque le plan de redressement
et de l'ordre de 100 milliards c'est un
accord comme ready pour le thème la
france est battue et 40 milliards
d'euros vont être injectés dans le plan
de relance français ou somme qui sera
disponible tout de suite pour remettre
l'économie française sur les rails où
iront ces fonds giron comme l'a rappelé
hier soir le président de la république
vers le verdissement de l'économie ils
iront vers les jeunes vers l'emploi vers
les entreprises vers ce qui va faciliter
la relocalisation d'un certain nombre
d'activités industrielles qui est sûre
notre indépendance on l'a vu à quel
point nous étions vulnérables s'agissant
des médicaments des appareils des
équipements médicaux
donc nous devons créer les conditions
favorables à un retour d'un certain
nombre d'activités
ceci est gage notre indépendance
économique technologique sanitaires
c'est aussi le gage de la création
d'emplois et puis il ya cette immense
effort à accomplir
j'espère parce que le cadre financier
pluriannuel
a été revu légèrement à la baisse
j'espère que le parlement va parvenir à
ajuster certains points notamment des
crédits erasmus dont ont tant besoin les
jeunes pour aller à la rencontre de
l'europe et pour parfaire leur formation
en se préparant en s'ouvrant à
l'international quelque peu de 90 heures
de négociations et on sait que les pays
dits frigo qui ne souhaitait pas ce plan
ont finalement accepté en obtenant un
rabais de leurs contributions au budget
de l'union européenne est ce un
compromis équitable sont en vous c'est
un compromis et donc il faut que chacun
y trouve son compte mais c'est vrai que
c'est assez choquant que qu'un pays je
pense aux pays bas par exemple vous
savez que les seules ressources propres
de l'union européenne du budget l'union
européenne ce sont les droits de douane
qui sont perçus et sur les importations
venant de pays tiers
l'essentiel arrive par amsterdam et
rotterdam et bien à l'occasion des
précédents cadre financier pluriannuel
les nantais sont parvenus à négocier et
qu'ils gardent 20% et des droits de
douane qui aurait dû revenir au budget
de l'union européenne elle c'est une
position que je ne faut pas légitime que
je ne trouve pas équitable d'autant que
les pays bas qui se sont montrés
extrêmement rétifs sont ceux qui
pratiquent le rétine fiscal de deux pics
fiscale les géants du gaf 1 qui ne
paient pas d'impôts en europe grâce aux
pays bas peuvent faire transiter des
faux qui s'accumulent en irlande et les
destiner vers les bermudes
il ya un certain nombre de grandes
holdings de sociétés internationales je
pense à edf sa renault et quelques
autres qui sont implantés aux pays bas
et donc ils ont incontestablement des
avantages c'est plus facile de se
prétendre bon gestionnaire et quand on
bénéficie d'un tel à point donc les
positions qu'ils ont prises extrêmement
rigoureuse et de ce point de vue
l'europe et les différents pays
notamment la france doivent se montrer
rigoureux
dans l' usage des fonds publics mais
dans le cas particulier c'était des
positions des négociations il y avait
également les râper les fameux rabais et
rabais qui ont été consentis à quelques
pays
lorsque madame thatcher avait bavé pu
obtenir un rabais ê pour la grande
bretagne le break site fait que le
royaume-uni shore de l'union européenne
est normalement tous ces rabais aurait
pu disparaître
eh bien ils ont été maintenus et même
légèrement augmenté
donc on voit bien que c'est le fruit
d'un compromis
l'europe est tenu par une règle qui
t'ont tina voilà ressortir notamment
l'unanimité je pense que l'heure est
venue de revoir les traités le système
actuel système de gouvernance actuelle
est à bout de souffle
donc je fais le voeu que tirant les
conséquences de cette grande décision
politique d'endettement commun parce que
quand on s'endette ensemble c'est que
l'on reconnaît qu'on a une vraie
solidarité qu'on a un destin commun un
avenir commun merci beaucoup
j'en retiens d'avoir répondu à nos
questions en direct ce matin je rappelle
que vous êtes ancien député européen et
ancien bonne journée